and i'll never forget going to his
funeral which was like in the bottom of
the perry's funeral home in newark and
it was like descending into the hull of
a ship we were all tied together in
grief wailing and moaning chained to
this horrific daily occurrence in
america which is another young boy in a
box
and and and it haunts me to this day and
i regret it to this day that i didn't do
more and so i i don't know what it will
take for all of us
to understand that we are so connected
that what you do matters
no matter how busy you are there's
something more you can do to end this
death the pain the hurt and so my appeal
to the folks here is that democracy is
not a spectator sport if there's ever a
time to change something it's it's right
now
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to roll on where
to
i might add very well-dressed
sartorially conscious podcaster one an
ocean swimming journalist and author
that would be you adam the other an
ultra endurance athlete turned writer
and podcaster namely me
bring our perspective on culture on
world events on art sports politics and
try to just uh make a little more sense
of this crazy world that we live in
while we're at it
what do you think
i think that's the
perfect perfect encapsulation to what we
do here rich
it was concise i think it's the most
well descriptive
piece on the roll-on yet
well we continue to iterate on this
format and play around with bringing new
things to you guys so we've got a very
exciting show today first we're going to
talk about a few interesting headlines
from the world of endurance which has
kind of become our habit here
we're going to share a few things we've
been enjoying respectively but really
the thrust of today's discussion
is focused on a more
sobering subject to say the least
specifically
america's perplexing problem and
obsession with guns
why rational gun control continues to
elude us and what we can and perhaps
should expect to be done about it it's a
discussion that will be bookended by a
call with senator cory booker which is
very exciting he was kind enough to
join us with his thoughts on this heated
and
important matter so let's kick it off
i'm going to begin with my standard
opener how go you mr skolnick
rich should i ever tell you about the
time i realized i was dead broke in the
middle of mongolia you did not you you
somehow forgot to share that story with
me i was in a supermarket
in mongolia
when i realized i was running low on
cash i had weeks to go in this research
trip was early on
and i was i attempted
to
uh what do they say push
was it push i guess
take a month off paying for my car
delay my car payment yeah that's a very
uh
i don't know i was attempting to
you know i built up a little bit of
wiggle room and so i was attempting to
basically decline to pay
and in actuality accidentally paid three
times the normal car payment how did you
happen to i don't want to get into the
technical difficulties no financial
wizard you
so that's what i tell you from this
story it broke halfway into it that
broke you spent all your money over
paying for your car and stranded
yourself yeah that was mongolia in the
middle of mongolia
luckily no ubers there was no ubers
there there was a camel i called for an
uber and a camel came over
five stars
but uh but luckily
my future wife april wong happened to be
with me and she's forgiving of your
financial oversight and she was in much
better financial condition than i at the
time so the lonely planet continued
and uh on we went into the gobi desert
the planet became a little less lonely
yes and i thought about that because i
was having this weird scent
memory you know how memory and scent are
kind of like connected
and today april played this morning uh
while i was making breakfast she played
an indian song that she remembered from
her travels
and i swear to god i would this ended up
getting us into this mongolia discussion
but
while she was playing this song that i
hadn't heard
heard before i swear i smelled nog
champa mm-hmm does that ever happen to
you you hear something a memory is
triggered and you smell something that's
not there usually it's the other way
around it smells something and it
triggers
the extreme
vividness of a memory that i didn't even
remember that i had right like i was i
swear to god i smelled like like the
incense wafting in varanasi you know
like when i was there and i was i was
like
anyway so hence the
hence the mala beads that you're wearing
today i'm in a maybe it's all related
you know i got into the beads during my
deadline that was just like
all-encompassing when i had that poofy
beard
and i the all of a sudden i started
wearing beads is there a story behind
where you procured said beads no i'm not
sure i have like a whole
rack of beads of different kinds i i was
uh i was deeply into beads at one time
i'm not i'm less so now
so now i'm rocking them they're not the
provenance of some
you know holy guru figure no but i used
to um you actually use them because i'd
use them to do meditations whatever um
and so now i don't meditate quite that
way where i'm where i'm doing mantra
meditations
and so i haven't used them in a while
but i used to actually use them so i'd
pick them up wherever
um
but yeah there you go otherwise the
deadline beard is dead i know the the
beads would have gone well with the with
the beard though
they did better well i wore them last
time yeah
but did you wear them on top of your
shirt i think they were tucked in this
time they're on top because
if i don't want to get into the whole
biological issue of a hairy chest and
beads but it's not always comfortable
right
well
there's something to the idea that
you're wearing mala beads and i'm
my feet are adorned in vegan
birkenstocks right now we're going to
talk about gun control a couple
progressive libtards yes we're going to
pontificate upon we are
this you know very
heightened issue two strikes against us
right off the bat
[Laughter]
hopefully you're not hopefully you're
not watching this you're just listening
to it and you think those guys make a
lot of sense i had to ditch my
flip-flops for the berks right but
what's going on with you man that was
happening with there you go that was the
prompt i was like you see i have to like
spoon feed you well i didn't know if we
were done talking about me i always
assume we're still talking about me we
can do that
we know the audience a lot we could just
do it do it we can do a whole show
tell me more adam
what other tales from the lonely planet
can you should i ever tell you by the
time i was in jordan and i went up to a
shawarma stand i was pretty vegan and i
had no idea if i could afford a shawarma
hmm
you did not but you know what we're
gonna put a pin in that and you can tell
that story some other time
back to my vegan birkenstocks yes
um
so
and this relates to like my fitness and
my back problems that i've shared about
uh i'm working with a pt right now
who has me
who who basically said you got to get
rid of the flip-flops okay very painful
uh council
because essentially i just if i'm not
wearing solomon running shoes i'm
wearing flip-flops right
that's my preferred footwork and you
could forget about chuck taylor's if
he's if the flip flops are out the
window pairs of chuck taylors but not
gonna work for the back i was told no
bueno
uh and told that the the vegan
birkenstocks would would would would be
a better option so that's why i'm
wearing those today but yeah so so wait
so you're saying dad shoes it took you a
long time to get to dad's shoes but you
should consider that a victory i have
some dad shoes and i had to i'll get to
it but i had to kind of do a thing in
san diego the other day and i had to go
buy a pair of dad's shoes because i
don't have any any sort of respectable
shoes that i can wear in a in a more
formal setting anyway i'll get to that
all right um but yeah so as i've shared
like i've had these back problems and
it's really got me
benched from doing the things that i
love swimming biking and running i've
sort of been told like
not now we've got to work on these other
things and so i've been focused on all
of these annoying little physiotherapy
exercises that are all about
activating my glutes and my hamstrings
because they're so weak in comparison to
these other muscle groups
and it's not even strength exercises
it's really just getting these muscles
to fire because when i tell my brain
like move my leg in a certain way like
it doesn't move or i use the wrong
muscles to move it so it's been really
educational and interesting playing
around with that but you know i hate it
it's annoying you hate you hate the pt i
want to go i want to go run i know
i want to go swim i want to do these
other things
i'm committed i'm all in
i'm trying to do these pelvic mobility
exercises and this whole like routine
straps straps and things i'm not even at
the straps yet i'm more i'm i'm at the
more elementary phase okay this whole
thing
which is required kind of a new level of
humility and russians right um because i
want to just burst out the door but
here's where i'm at i'm accepting of it
and
committed to this journey and we'll see
where it heads but i haven't had any
huge back flare-ups it's not like my
back pain has gone away but you know
hopefully i'm on a good trajectory with
all of this so that's great
and you look and you look fantastic and
that's what counts
the hair and makeup person just left you
can thank them okay
uh but it's been a cool week my my
eldest daughter mathis graduated from
high school that was exciting i can't
believe that she already graduated from
high school it's just crazy
congratulations do i congratulate you a
newborn no
don't graduate graduate uh or
congratulate mathis i know but do people
congratulate the parent in that regard i
do it's a little weird especially
because it's high school it's like you
should be able to graduate high school i
think so
i think so
it's worthy of celebration though yes
yes
and then i had to jet from that to go
down to san diego
uh where i attended this conference
called life itself which is this event
that
sanjay gupta
personal friend friend of the podcast
um
created in partnership with this other
guy called mark hodush who was the owner
and co-founder of ted med okay and they
created this new conference called life
itself sanjay had just sort of invited
me to attend and i didn't know you guys
were buddies
super buddies um yeah we met we met uh
like i think back in like 2013 okay did
a story on me and we've just stayed in
touch
and i just went with no expectations i
didn't really spend a lot of time
researching what it was all about i just
thought it would be cool and nice to
support sanjay and he was kind enough to
invite me to attend and then
a couple days before the event he texted
me and he's like hey
uh i think it would be really cool if
you did like a fireside chat with lance
armstrong
think about that so it went from being
like oh i'm just gonna chill out to oh
now i have to like do a thing and of
course i'm gonna say yes to that
uh but um
but then it was like okay what do i ask
lance how is this gonna go it's just a
20 minute thing but it ended up being
great
really fun the speakers at this
conference were off the chain like next
level
thinkers geniuses at the cutting edge of
health and biotech and longevity
i saw you know
um
more than a few people who i just love
to get on the podcast and also
presentations by people who have been on
the podcast like david sinclair and
ariana huffington dean ornish sanjay of
course
uh and what's cool is
the presentations are slowly being
dripped out on cnn.com
uh the one i did with lance i'll let you
guys judge how that went uh should be up
there soon it's not up there yet but if
you go to cnn.com life itself you can
see some of the presentations again with
more being dripped out so
it's really fun it was it was it was an
incredibly inspiring uplifting event i
go to a lot of conferences and this was
like a cut above
basically anything else i've ever
attended how how forthcoming was lance
were you getting into the nitty-gritty
or had you done that kind of you hadn't
done it yeah podcast several you did
yeah yeah um and you know i i guess i
would just say watch the video okay you
guys make up your own mind you know
all right i'll leave it there sounds
like sounds like you were hard-hitting
no no what are you going to do in 20
minutes or like 20 minutes i'm like
that's one question so did you do it
i can do
two to three hours 20 minutes is much
more stressful right that's much harder
how do you even get your head around
that like it's not in my
skill set or tool i actually think it is
you know like i always thought
after uh
our first interview and then like kind
of listening to your show i always
thought like you're one of the best
interviewers there is so you could do
any format i always thought like your
destiny was
like nbc was going to come calling or 60
minutes was going to come calling that's
what i always thought
um this could be the beginning of it
very very kind of you know it's about
that very kind of you to say yeah um
we'll see i like doing what i'm doing
now i know i'm not doing this so that i
can get another thing i know i'm not
implying that that was your idea i'm
just saying i could see it i will say it
went well people seem to really enjoy it
um so
you guys can decide and when it when it
goes up i'll share it out on social
media beautiful yeah uh final thing
before we get into the next uh little
segment is i just want to thank
everybody who joined
the giveaway for the 50 copies of
finding ultra that we're
handing out um
to kind of celebrate the 10th
anniversary we got a lot a big response
out of that
that uh
opportunity closes on june 9th which is
the day this podcast is going up we're
recording this on what is it the sixth
today which is monday uh but in any case
we're going to announce the winner soon
and just appreciate everybody who kind
of signed up for the mailing list and we
also got
a lot of cool ideas about how to
leverage that mailing list
to create something that people would
actually enjoy seeing in their inbox as
opposed to feeling irritated and quickly
unsubscribing oh right
or you could be like me and just never
unsubscribe and just watch these emails
come into your book and start taking up
residence in your inbox i subscribe to
some sub stacks and some newsletters and
i would say that more often than not
like i just don't have time to even read
them right and no matter how many times
i unsubscribe from mailing lists that i
never signed up for every day i would
say like 60 to 70 of the incoming emails
are just from
lists that i never signed up for and i'm
just constantly deleting emails
is that your inbox experience
my inbox experience is i never delete
them and then i have like 30 000 emails
and then gmail says you have 90 you have
one percent left and then i go on a mad
like
slash and burn
yeah
clear cutting delete them as i go well i
delete them as i go and then when i'm
busy i just leave unread the ones that i
need to go back to right and then it's a
crap shoot as to whether i ever go back
to them i'm gonna start deleting as i go
irritation with people that you know i'm
trying to do stuff with really do you
ever have you ever had i've had that
once where
i was just sick of getting this one
newsletter
i unsubscribed
and then i thought like at the time this
was way back at the time i thought
um that there's some bot like that
person is never going to see me do that
they know they they look at their
unsubscribe so they know that you
then i found out i got like unfollowing
somebody
like a bad habit hey you invited that i
did i did i was i was i wasn't i wasn't
upset
all right well let's start uh with the
light before we go into the dark uh we
need to report back on the sub seven
hour iron man project
uh i think it's fair to say that this
podcast is now officially a christian
blumenfeldt stan account oh yeah in
light of his accomplishment this past
weekend uh it seems like we're checking
in on christian every single week here
because he's constantly you know
breaking records and right eclipsing
ceilings on what he's capable of oh yeah
i mean every time he races it seems like
he's doing something special so right so
yeah our favorite norseman did it again
just to recap in the last 12 months
this guy was not only crowned olympic
champion he claimed the wtc series
championship he set the fastest recorded
ironman ever in cozumel i guess that's
not a world record though there were
some
no it wasn't it's not considered
a world record because of the down
current swim in cozumel and like
something about the bike distance but
then when he won in st george it was the
fastest time ever at a world
championship but it was not the same
course as in previous years so he was
most recently crowned world champion in
saint george and now
he's become the first ever athlete to go
under seven hours in an iron distance
triathlon as part of the this sub 7
project
which
uh much like the the sub two marathon
project where kipchoge was trying to go
under two hours in the marathon
this allowed for drafting they created a
course that was very conducive to going
fast
and not only did christian go under
seven hours he absolutely demolished it
he went six hours and 44 minutes
which included a 225 marathon which was
unbelievable
um there's some
graphics uh that i found on social media
that i wanted to share and it was
supposed he was supposed to go up he was
supposed to go this was actually a race
he was supposed to go up against
alistair brownlee but he got ruled out
he had a stress response to his hip and
so they brought in joe skipper who
happened to be the guy that had been
trash talking norwegian smack talker
which makes for better television is
great and he and he [ __ ] he threw
down he he was not messing around no he
was not messing around he was ahead as
you know off the bike right so so yeah
so christian got out of the swim at 45
joe was 49
and then joe just threw down an
unbelievable
bike leg
uh going three hours and 20 minutes 316.
or is it 360. yeah yeah those are the
projections
sorry i was looking at the projections
um
yeah three oh so yeah christian swam 48
joe swam 53 and then joe threw down a 3
16 on the bike that's riding 112 miles
in three hours and 16 minutes that's
unbelievable unbelievable that's crazy
how's that even possible eight minutes
faster than christian but christian you
know he knows how to stay within himself
and not race anybody other than himself
stick to his plan and
uh so is that a 30 mile an hour or
greater than 30 mile an hour average
speed i can't do math it's fast
jeez yeah it's unbelievable um but then
christian so christian threw down oh his
i'm sorry i misspoke about his marathon
i said he ran 225 but he he ran 230.
right and joe ran 236 i mean
these are crazy
fast so
christian went 644 and joe went 647. yes
unbelievable
and then on the women's side
um they called that the sub 8 project uh
nicola spring
and kat matthews both
uh readily eclipsed the eight hour mark
amazing 734 and cat went 731.
um these times are look at those
marathons on those two i know 245 and
246 marathons and apparently so when joe
went by uh christian on the bike he
talks [ __ ] this is supposedly what
happened i didn't get to see the i i saw
a little bit i read about it but i
didn't get to see or hear the the
the record the i guess whatever that he
said and then uh on the run christian
gave him a little little something on
the way
when he passed him at like the 17k mark
i don't know i couldn't find anybody
that had the transcript what they said
unbelievable um i know there was a live
cast i i didn't catch it i know you
didn't catch it either
but i heard that it was really well done
and
um i think that's interesting because in
contrast the wtc that oversees iron man
they always live cast the iron man races
and they're pretty notorious for being
substandard people are always
complaining about them showing the wrong
thing or being in the wrong place at the
wrong time and all this kind of glitchy
and all that kind of stuff but
apparently uh with this sub 7 sub 8 um
broadcast like they crushed it yeah so
hopefully you know iron man needs to get
its [ __ ] together when it comes to these
live casts yeah yeah i mean no no doubt
i mean
it it worked and people loved it and it
and uh it sounds like everyone was
really thrilled to be a part of it and
it seemed like christian loved being
part of even though he is part of team
norway and they do work together as a
team um as a lot of triathletes do it
can be you're out there racing alone so
it seemed like he enjoyed the like the
big team you know they had like
obviously world-class marathoners pacing
them they had professional cyclists
pacing them
um
so uh you know
it must have been fun to be in in a pack
and to be able to work that way i mean
two observations before we move on one
obviously the course was fast but it
really just goes to show you how
significant drafting is yeah you know if
you can go that much faster i mean
basically when you're tucked in on the
bike behind a group that's breaking the
wind for you
there is an effortlessness to the whole
thing that makes a huge difference so
not only does that
count towards the incredible bike splits
but also allows them to be super fresh
for the run fair
and the second observation being that
let's not forget we pointed this out in
the last roll on
christian was not
prioritizing this this is just kind of
like a one-off thing for fun that they
weren't even really focused on right so
the fact that he goes you know he went
as fast as he did without overthinking
it too much is kind of amazing it's
definitely amazing i mean i mean i i
wouldn't say he was fresh as a daisy on
the run he said he had uh cramps at the
10k mark and i'm thinking
i had cramps last night in the middle of
the night as i was sleeping so oh adam
yeah
and i almost cried but he finished his
marathon yeah well you can call larry
david about it
um good for you krishnan we look forward
to getting you on the podcast uh
after
kona all right that's when we're doing
it after kona are we going after are we
doing kona i don't know
probably not oh all right we'll see
maybe
i said i would look into it and i've
done nothing to look into it since we
last talked about it so that's what i've
done i don't know all right well then
we're just in the same place we were
like okay let's just check back um the
other uh thing that caught my eye in in
terms of uh you know
news from the world of sports and
endurance yes is uh this terry mckeever
story so terry mckeever
is a legendary coach in swimming she's
been the head coach of the uc berkeley
women's team for
many many years she i think she's
basically i think it's fair to say she's
the most prominent
most victorious female coach in swimming
history
i mean she's about my age she's been
around forever i've
i don't know her personally but i've you
know even like way back in the day like
she was around like everybody in
swimming knows her
she was suspended and has been put on
administrative leave
uh in the wake of this scandal where
more than 20 current or former athletes
of her have come out to report bullying
and verbal abuse on her behalf so
this is a kind of
you know set off a bit of a earthquake
in the swimming world right you know
basically she's you know being one of
swimming's leading coaches
and the architect of one of college
sports premier programs i mean she's
produced olympians and nc2a champions
and all kinds of standouts both in the
pool and in the the classroom for
decades she's the only she's the first
and only women woman head coach of the
us olympic team
she led a squad that included six future
current or former cow swimmers who
earned a combined 13 medals at the 2012
games in london she's won four nc2a team
titles she's produced 26 olympians
who have combined for 36 olympic medals
and 29 seasons in berkeley
so
you can't argue with her track record
and yet
this story breaks and not for nothing it
was
broke by the orange county register
which is kind of an interesting outlet
to kind of break
they have a paywall i know but paywall
so i've got like two articles
here but i can't get past the paywall
like but in any event like what's
interesting is the orange county region
it's like a little local paper yeah but
they consistently break big stories in
the swimming world for some reason so
whoever is on the swimming beat here is
like on top of their game yeah no doubt
um in any event uh
in this expose
uh
we learned that at least
six cal women swimmers since 2018 have
made plans to kill themselves or
obsessed about suicide due to
mckeever's bullying
24 current and former cow swimmers eight
parents a former member of the golden
bears men's team and two former cal
athletic department employees
have told the kind of safety and sport
organization that mckeever was a bully
who for decades
has
allegedly verbally and emotionally
abused swear at and threatened swimmers
on an almost daily basis
pressuring them to compete or train
while injured or dealing with chronic
illnesses or eating disorders
it just goes on and on and on it's like
it does not paint a very good
picture and uh
no
sounds like the uh like the bobby knight
of the swimming night of the swim game
so so the broader kind of conversation
around this is
around this um philosophy of coaching
that bobby knight school of coaching
that when it all costs kind of
philosophy right uh we're we're kind of
seeing the end of that
for good reason right there was a period
of time i mean back when i swam my coach
exhibited a lot of these you know some
similar
coach skip county right skip kenny right
yeah you know i thought he got he
he got uh
deposed on a similar situation he
ultimately his downfall was the result
of he had a personal grudge against one
particular swimmer named jason plummer
who recently passed away this past year
i think we talked about that on roll on
yeah and he hated jason so much
that he doctored the uh
the record board like the all-time
performance list and remove jason's name
from the record boards even though jason
had had swum times that would have
you know allowed him to be on those
lists jason called him out on it there
was a big scandal and ultimately
you know skip had to step down so he was
on cooking the books that's it he cooked
the books but
then there was
there's a lot of other stuff and we
don't need to get into it now but the
point being that you know he was pretty
hardcore and this was the 80s and that
was a time where you could get away with
that stuff and and maybe even get
praised for it like it was definitely
those people bobby knight was revered by
these basketball journalists so
culturally we've moved forward and
thankfully this is no longer acceptable
i had no idea i mean i'd heard stories
that terry was a hard charging coach but
i had no idea the extent to which you
know this this was going on so i read
one of these stories that you had up
there um
the more recent one
apparently like
because the athletic director is saying
all the right things now but apparently
was sitting on this information for ages
and had been it's been going on forever
right and he and he's been he's been
fielding these same complaints of the oc
uh registered journalists has has now
documented this is like prize-winning
stuff because he's he's shaking the core
of this incredible swim program but
apparently like they were contacted then
by someone who was supposed to be like
an assistant coach there that maybe they
thought was taking over and the swimmers
came to what they thought was a meeting
and she was there
and she's like and basically said are
you guys ready to swim and they all
bailed right and then you know like you
had to chase them out or she had i don't
jesse so and so i don't know if it's a
male or a female
but
so like even as this was ongoing that
she terry was still there basically
trying to hold court right and then
finally that's what was the last straw
and they they made the announcement so
you know
berkeley trying to cover their ass like
saying they care about the swimmers it's
like you know
a person like terry mckeever they rev
that it's not just journalists that
revere her or whoever it's the ads that
revere her and like she's produced so
much for the school we can't shake we
can't shake this up like the track
record right and then that's how
these these people get continue
generation after you know year after
year i mean she's been up there for a
whole generation
basically right
oh yeah yeah i mean i think she's
she's 56 or something 60 it says here
and you know been in coaching you know
shortly after she graduated college if
memory serves me so there you go um and
it's just interesting you know this this
philosophy of of
being so intense to drive performances i
mean your her track record demonstrates
that on some level
i guess you could make the argument that
it was effective but it's a short-term
solution like that's what she would make
the argument but but in college you only
need short-term and olympics you only
need short-term you only have the same
roster once
i just never responded to that no i just
don't think like now with everything
that we know it's unacceptable like you
want to bring out the best in your
athletes like empower them give them
agency make that
coach athlete relationship
a collaboration where there's open
communication and a sense of
empowerment
but this idea like you're a piece of
[ __ ] like these girls were all reporting
like they were so
uh driven for her approval that it drove
them to you know the the edge of like
mental health insanity right
so
anyway
well
another one down yeah i know right like
how many coaches are are still out there
who are behaving badly like this
probably a lot
i would guess a lot now i guess a lot
i don't know
uh let's move on this is also a robbie
ballinger stan account yes podcast and
robbie ballinger and we've all talked at
length about his colorado crush where he
went out and spent a whole summer doing
all this crazy stuff he
he ran up all the 14ers in colorado he
ran the leadville and the colorado trail
and all that kind of stuff in any event
they have made a documentary about this
that was uh directed by
friend and friend of the podcast reese
robinson reese used to work with us and
take pictures and make videos with us
okay um and reese you know followed
robbie around for the better part of
that experience and they've created
something special it's going to debut on
on june 8th on robbie's new endurance
platform on youtube which is called what
is it called the audacious report i
think it's robbie and reese together are
behind that one yeah exactly and oh
they're they launched that channel
together the audition it's not just it's
not just a channel it's a platform so
they have a website and the website is
going to be a place to go to to you know
check out films podcasts and articles
featuring
endurance athletes cool i didn't know
that where did you read about that
robbie told me about it that's very cool
yeah so go to the audacious report
youtube channel you can watch the the
trailer for the colorado crush it's
already up if you're watching this on
youtube you can see it here and then
june 8 which actually that's the the day
up by the time this podcast yeah which
is cool
and you'll find it on that youtube
channel and and uh yeah the idea is to
for is also for athletes to consider
that they just report a place to
announce big adventures and goals and
things like that right on so cool um
congrats guys yeah awesome and the film
is great i saw it oh you did yeah i got
a sneak peek
and it's uh it's fabulous the
cinematography is wonderful it's really
intimate you really feel like you're
part of the crew watching robbie do this
stuff and and and then also seeing the
uh how spectacular the scenery is and
where he's doing it it's it's it's
really cool it's got that big
feel but also the intimate uh kind of
fly on the wall
feel as well so congrats guys all right
man well i look forward to talking about
it yep um before we take a quick break
you want to uh talk about our our next
favorite person the other people bernie
another person we stand for bo burnham
the the funniest man alive
today so good he is the funniest man
alive right
uh
he's pretty damn funny i think he's the
funniest guy lives today talented yes
creative person um he released outtakes
from his special that we talked about at
length on the podcast yeah
inside where he just strings together on
youtube for free
uh all this stuff that didn't make it
into the final cut and it's an epic
watch it's amazing
everybody i i think i have 10 minutes to
go i've been just this has been nibbling
on it it's it's it's
got outtakes of stuff that you'll
recognize it's got completely new
numbers that he never put into the
podcast
including i mean in the film including a
podcast right that's the one that seems
to be resonating on social media and
getting shared the most
so it's it's pretty transparent who he's
poking fun at yeah in that uh and i'll
just leave it at that you guys can check
it out but it's it's pretty incisive
yeah and and and there's more uh jeff
bezos trolling which i'm always here
there's a couple things in there but he
just can't get off the bezos obsession i
i think like now he would do an elon
so like if he was making the next one
don't you think elon would be someone
he'd go after
i love the fact that that he's such a
prolific
creator and really a product of social
media and youtube yes but he's mature
enough now to really not participate in
the social media ecosystem other than to
tweet like once every eight months that
he has some new thing out to share with
everybody yeah and everyone goes wild
yeah yeah good for him he's uh i feel
like somehow this was more depressing
though than the actual film hmm
i still have i've only watched a couple
clips so i haven't had time to sit
through pretty funny the whole thing
pretty fun um but bo if you're listening
i'm going to remove adam from his seat
and place you there if you're ever so
inclined oh it would be an incredible
podcast not not on the way so i can't be
here i can't i can't hear you but i
can't i can't
all right let's take a quick break and
then we'll come back with our main topic
prophets walk among us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years i've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share
those that we don't know who can teach
us something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so i've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why i'm proud to announce the release of
my new book
voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper
voicing change is a physical
manifestation of the magic
inspiration
and timeless wisdom that transpires each
week on the ritual podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying stand-alone work picking
up this book allows you to revisit the
wisdom of your favorite everyday
prophets
and physically interact with the
life-changing ideas contained within
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
should we talk about guns adam
i think we have to
we do have to yeah how do we do this
though it's so difficult to figure out
how to approach this subject matter it's
so devastating and unwieldy
um and uncomfortable you know i think we
can all agree that what we've borne
witness to
just over the last couple weeks
[Music]
is
heartbreaking to say the least
and
i've struggled with
how to think about this how to approach
it i do feel compelled i feel like a
responsibility to discuss it even though
it's not fun on the podcast
um
[Music]
but how do we structure this you have a
thought yeah i mean i think
if we frame it like this this is the
deal
so we're 23 years since the columbine
massacre which was
shook everybody up that was in a high
school outside of denver
a decade since sandy hook which i
thought at the time would have been the
event that spurred action
because there's nothing you could you
couldn't imagine a worse thing
than what was it kindergartners being
targeted by a madman with an ar-15
um and then we're only 10 days since
buffalo since that
racist massacre in a in a supermarket
where 10 died
and then you know we had just talked
about
the murder in austin
of an athlete right mo wilson mo wilson
and recorded that yeah literally the day
before uvalde yeah and you had pointed
out this issue around guns which was
sort of prophetic
and then i had to kind of append the
blog post and the social media posts
around that episode to remind people
that we had recorded it in advance of
vivaldi and that's why you know it was
not discussed
yeah but i mean i guess the real
question i think people want to know
from you is kind of how did this land
for you where were you how did you like
what what were your feelings when you
heard this was going on and and um
like what were you doing were you paying
close attention to it were you trying to
avoid it because it was so heavy like
what were you doing i mean in between
you know i wasn't glued to the 24-hour
news cycle uh but of course i was you
know paying attention to what was going
on i mean it's devastating you know as a
parent of uh you know such a young
person when you become a parent it
becomes
all that more heightened i mean it's
unbelievable in elementary school like
how could this possibly happen
and when you think about
the 23 years since columbine
and the decades since sandy hook and
then you consider the fact that in
the short period of time between uvalde
and today there's actually been
23 more
mass shootings in the united states like
look at this article like it's
unbelievable i don't know how they're
defining mass shootings like i think
it's three or more or more three or more
all school shootings but no um
it's it's really
devastating and it's so strange that no
matter what happens we can't seem to
move forward in any kind of meaningful
way to address this problem so i want to
talk about
that of course
i don't know that i can offer
anything that hasn't already been said
particularly with respect to like the
emotional experience of what we've all
collectively experienced yeah i mean i
think it because it unfolded it was like
i mean i was busy
day after day during this whole thing
and at some point i plugged into it
right around the time when we started to
realize that the police line on this
thing was some [ __ ]
and that there were complications and to
say the least and how they addressed
this problem and how there was somebody
else a whole other right but like
yeah and so then when that was going on
is when i kind of plugged into it and it
was just
you know when you have
parkland and columbine then you have
sandy hook and evaldi
and uh
you just
it's hard not to be super angry about
the whole thing you're angry you're
you're you're despairing you're like you
know i'm
in my house we we're friends with a lot
of families with young kids obviously
and and the moms are just like you know
looking for other places to live you
know like that don't have this problem
let me give you some statistics i found
to show you why people are kind of
leaning in that direction
gun deaths so far in 2020 20 22 just so
far the first six months not even full
six months five five five months and
change
18 697 gun deaths
of those 8
335 are murders
10 362 are suicides hold on let me just
interrupt you yes these statistics are
coming from this site called
gunviolencearchive.org and in the time
between you jotted those stats down in
this outline
on sunday yeah then you know earlier
today that
gun death total was at 18
700 and i just refreshed it just now and
it went up to 18713
right so it's just it get it notches up
minute by minute right and they have uh
you know they have 7 500 sources they're
they're getting law enforcement reports
they're getting government uh sources
and media sources that's how they're
it's kind of like
i guess farming the internet to come up
with this uh this database and uh
284 murder suicides that's a plus four
since sunday
uh 246 mass shootings in 2022 already 12
mass murders 153 children under 11 were
killed 320 are injured i know this is
hard to hear i'm not trying to
make it worse but i think it's important
for us to understand this as a baseline
for the rest of this conversation
554 teens killed
1451 injured 25 police officers killed
162 injured or killed 485 gun events
used in a defensive situation so that's
485
in a defensive situation 634
unintentional shootings and 512 school
shootings in the united states in
primary insect or secondary school since
2014. right so amongst all of those
statistics the ones that jump out to me
as most egregious and and heart
wrenching are 153 children under 11
killed
and 512 school shootings in the u.s
since 2014.
and this is not a problem that other
countries have this is completely unique
to the united states
it's not even close i mean listen you
have you have um the best examples are
in uh the 90s there was a mass shooting
at a workplace i believe in australia
and immediately they changed they
changed the law and people voluntarily
gave up their guns new zealand
after the christchurch uh massacres at
the mosques
overnight took care of it they took care
of business
there's something going on here and you
can point to the constitution if you
want that's what a lot of people are
going to go to but there's something
going on here it's to me it's a little
bit deeper than that
obviously that's part of it but um we
are not willing to change
in the face of these kinds of outcomes
not only are we not willing to
change completely on a dime like some of
those other countries have but we're
also not willing to even do incremental
changes and it's not that we're not
willing it's that somehow the political
apparatus isn't set up to be able to get
that done
so because the majority people are
willing for to do that right and we're
going to get into that yeah
what's your take on this well we're
we're offering listen adam we're
offering up lots of prayers and lots of
thoughts
that's not nothing right right right
you know look
i will preface
my take on this by saying that i'm not
against gun ownership there's lots of
people that responsibly own guns that's
fine most gun owners are responsible
i'm not a gun person but i have friends
that are and
you know i think that that the
statistics bear out that
um most gun owners support rational and
reasonable gun control and we'll get
into those statistics and i support that
as well and i
you know i just think that there is
zero
reason
why it shouldn't be incredibly difficult
to purchase a gun
the bar to accessing a weapon
particularly a semi-automatic or an
automatic weapon
should be incredibly
difficult
every other thing
in the united states that is dangerous
or poses a safety threat to others is
heavily regulated and we accept that
except when it comes to guns and we'll
get into the reasons the culture
how it roots into the second amendment
and all this sort of stuff
but as you pointed out other countries
with responsible gun control just do not
have this issue so yeah i'm fed up i'm
despondent i'm sick of the thoughts and
the prayers
but i also feel this sense of despair or
powerlessness that anything will ever
get done here given
our social and political climate
yeah i mean i i
completely agree with you on everything
you just said
um it's difficult to believe it's going
to happen i will say for the first time
i feel like
even just some fear about like
it could happen i mean listen
there was a situation at zuma beach i
don't know if you ever heard about this
but there was someone that was arrested
here that deputies got to him and he had
several loaded uh automatic weapons in
his van
or in like he had a he had a trench coat
on in the middle of a summer day and it
was right where we swim a lot like just
like at zuma right where westward and
zuma's
it was like a year or two ago
and um and someone saw him and reported
him saw someone acting squirrely and
reported him and the cops got to him but
like he could have just gone down the
beach i mean like it could happen
anywhere
it's still a i'm not i don't want to
overstate the problem it is still the
odds are obviously
minuscule that it will happen to you but
it could happen to you anytime anywhere
you live
and um and for the first time that fear
is kind of dripping in probably because
i have a young kid probably because my
wife is australian and she thinks it's
kind of
batshit crazy that nothing gets done
when you have this kind of a problem
like what does it take how many more
children
is it gonna take yeah and uh so i think
that i mean i
i also think like
when it comes to weapons like
ar-15s
um
you know to me it's like
i i always think of the joke of like
there should be no president who wants
to be president like you should we
should only have reluctant presidents
like people who want to be president
should be
immediately be disqualified from the job
right just on basis if they want it too
much you want it too much you're
immediately just right if you apply to
own an ar-15 you should immediately be
turned down just because you want it
only those that do not want ar-15 yes
get ar-15 that's that's in my fantasy
land so
uh but yeah for the most part i i'm with
you on on all this so
you know but how do we you know you want
to get you want to feel hopeful it's
hard to feel hopeful in this moment like
it was a very tough week um to be
thinking about everything that went down
the way it went down
the fact that this guy waited till he
was 18. 18
and then bought it even though he had a
problem even though he had social media
posts out there did he buy them online
i can't no i think he went to a gun shop
or or a show
i don't know i thought but he i think he
bought him in person he waited until he
was 18. he um had social media posts
that were alarming out there nobody
reported him um
the the guy sandy hook was given a a gun
by his mom so like listen
age limits will only help so so much
because the mom gave him the gun in the
sandy hook situation so they're we're
not trying to say any solutions are
perfect solutions but it would be nice
to try something
right try something yeah let's get into
the solution rather than throw up our
hands and say well we can't solve this
problem there's nothing that can be done
we're just going to have to learn to
live with mass shootings like it's
insanity it is insanity and it's for
every proposed solution that you offer
there's a rebuttal as to why it won't
work trevor noah did a did a pretty
interesting monologue on this the other
day and i'll link that up in the show
notes i think i'll have it um up here
just so people can see but he basically
goes on this rant we're you know kind of
taking on that argument of why all these
things won't work and just basically
saying we have to do something right
okay it's not perfect and maybe it won't
work as well as we hope it might but we
have to be in the process of trying
these things and iterating it because
that's how you make progress but to sit
on your hands and just say well i guess
there's nothing we can do
is complete insanity right it's insanity
i mean right when it happened i i did uh
tweet out that this is not a mental
health issue it's an access to deadly
weapons issue i do believe that i don't
think it is a mental health issue i've
looked at the statistics anyone who says
that it is is kidding themselves that's
not to say people who do these things
are not mentally ill it's to say that
there's other countries with mentally
ill people where it doesn't happen and
the reason is they can't get the weapon
so it's the same thing we talked about
with mo's killer if if she was just
upset and distraught and and and like
having a breakdown but couldn't fire a
weapon
you know every there would be three
lives that would be
radically different right now yeah not
to mention all the family that doesn't
mean there isn't a mental health problem
clearly there's a mental health problem
and anybody who goes into an elementary
school and shoots it up is is mentally
unhappy of course but the problem
the fact that we have mental health
issues in this country is not the reason
it happened no it's the free unfettered
access to guns right that allows the
mentally unstable person to perpetrate
the harm that's what needs to be
addressed so
um why don't we go through all of these
things just as a caveat before getting
into that on the subject of ar-15s and
mass shootings and school shootings
in order to be kind of intellectually
rigorous about this i do think it's
important to point out that of course
the mass shootings and and particularly
the school shootings are going to
capture the headlines because it is so
devastating
but when you go to this gun violence
website and you look at the statistics
you realize that
those are you know but a very small
portion of
the total uh incidence of gun violence
injuries and deaths every year like you
can even go to all these charts
more than half for suicide so you know
the ar-15 is like the low-hanging fruit
right that's the gun of choice for these
sorts of incidents but most of these gun
violence incidents
are by dent of
you know a handgun generally you know
and often a semi-automatic handgun um
we'll get to some reporting around this
but david frum has been
pretty good on the subject matter as a
conservative traditional conservative
voice writing in the atlantic about this
topic and um he has some pretty
insightful things to say about how we
think about you know the the school
shootings versus
the bigger problem that goes less
addressed because it's so persistent and
endemic to our culture which is just gun
violence and you know private gun owners
in their home and how how when you have
a gun in the home
even for self-defense reasons it becomes
a catalyst for a lot of this harm
but in any case you know to kind of go
through these opposition points
you said the first one which is this is
a mental health issue not a gun issue
which is like the first thing all the
republican leaders were saying both you
know i think it's but it's a it's it
annoys me that we have to pick one or
the other of course it's both like can
we not talk about this in a nuanced way
we have a gun issue and we have a mental
health issue there are mental health
concerns like i said nobody shoots up at
school if they're not mentally unhinged
and we also can't
extricate uh
these individuals and the harm that
they're perpetrating from the impact
that social media is having on
radicalizing that's true these
individuals there's a new york times
article about this that certainly
happened
yeah that certainly happened at buffalo
he could go through
his entire social media diet and they
can pinpoint like
where he you know gets activated and how
he becomes
more um
inclined to violence uh by tracing the
videos he was watching et cetera et
cetera et cetera so you know that's the
larger issue also that comes into play
and i guess my point being that this is
not a
something that we can look at in a
binary context like these all these
complicated things are coming into play
not the least of which is gun culture
right yes when you're seeing on social
media these families where they're all
holding their ar-15s and things like
that like what is the message that we're
sending
and how is that being interpreted by
young people so
in my opinion we do need better mental
health programs
but the truth of the matter is for all
the decrying about how this is a mental
health issue and not a guns issue
uh
you know the republicans or the right
have really done very little
on either front it's right you know it's
sort of a talking point to say it's a
mental health issue but it's not like
they're hard at work in addressing that
no the governor of texas greg abbott in
april slashed over 200 million dollars
from the texas uh department budget that
oversees mental health services so this
is the and as soon as if all day
happened he he said it was a mental
health issue um this is
mental health has has never been mental
health has never been an issue
that republicans have championed in any
way in any budgetary kind of way it's
always been kind of a scapegoated thing
and it's it's it's it's all
and so this is what hap this is what's
happening so but when you say it's a
mental health issue not a guns issue and
then you do neither um you know why are
you in power that's the one thing i
wanna like when this something like this
happens right
you're in power you wanted power
you're there
how can you possibly want to be a a
power player and have see something like
this happen and do [ __ ] nothing
because you're
you're
inferring
that the reason they're in power is to
is to represent the people's best
interest when in truth power is there to
basically extend power right right
in order to extend power
you have to play to your base and you
have to appease the people who are
funding your campaigns so you get to
power and your service is power itself
it's not the children that you are
supposed to care for
it's just insanity i mean that leads to
the next opposition point which is my
favorite we need to arm the schools with
militias and we need to you know
restrict ingress with having just one
door right you know in and out of these
how would fire departments feel about
that
i mean
this idea
you know and and sort of ted cruz is the
face of this one
um
like let's just make sure that there are
armed militias outside of every school
and there should just be one door like
are you
like does he actually believe this
you know because to me i'm like you're
either stupid or you're a liar because
this is ins this is just more insanity
let's not let's not let's not look at
the real issue here which is how a young
person has such unfettered access to
a powerful
weapon that can destroy so many people
instead let's skirt around that and come
up with this other
absurd rationale for addressing this
situation so we can sidestep gun control
altogether
i don't think he's stupid
uh
but didn't he he can't believe in his
heart of hearts that this is a real but
that is a viable solution i have no idea
d do you didn't he go to the nr didn't
he isn't he one of the few people that
turned up there and spoke at the nra
convention
i believe he was i don't know i think he
did well one thing i know for sure
is that
when the uvalde funerals began he was
playing poker and he shared a video of
himself playing poker
which at the very to give him the most
charitable interpretation of that is in
unbelievably poor taste
i don't understand the mentality of
somebody who
thinks that that would be a good idea to
share that
video of him playing poker on social
media in the midst of this crisis
and to literally look at camera and talk
about
patrolling schools with militia
basically saying that the solution to
this gun problem is more guns which is
all the more absurd
by virtue of the fact
that the police completely bungled their
ability to
manage the uvalde situation and allowed
this kid
to go into the school and sat on their
hands and did nothing and even prevented
parents from jumping into action now
when you have a kid who's wearing a
bulletproof vest and he's completely
armed to the gills and he's got all of
these jacket you know like the
all of these um
uh what do you call them um the the the
grenades
oh the the the yeah the um
the cartridges the cartridges exactly
yes and this automatic rifle and then
you have cops who are out there they
they they don't they're not on an equal
footing with that and they're afraid of
their lives so
but you know you're supposed to you're
supposed to you're supposed to put your
life on the line for children if you're
a cop i mean you're supposed to but
basically it's exposing yeah the
fruitlessness of that option right i
mean you know it didn't work
um
i i have family members that have guns i
have no problem with people who are gun
owners responsibly i will say it takes a
special kind of [ __ ] to go to an nra
conference days after the uvalde
massacre that's my feeling about it like
if you go there
whether you're a spectator a purchaser
you're you have a gun show
you're speaking there
that says a lot that says a lot about
your priorities man what's interesting
about the nra and the power that it
wields as a lobbying organization is
that it's completely out of step with
its membership because if you look at
the polling and the statistics
you realize that people overwhelmingly
support rational gun control like yes
you pulled together some polling i did
you want to go through it yeah maybe
let's just go through that right now
okay
um
so the majority of americans support the
right to own a gun that's just the facts
40 of households have at least one
firearm this is uh a lot of this is from
this pew research uh study that came out
in september 2021 so they did a lot of
polling on it
on on this issue and from a variety of
vantage points
and came up with this so the majority of
americans do support gun ownership 40 of
households have at least one firearm but
three-quarters of americans believe gun
violence is a big or moderately big
problem
and uh 53 percent favors stricter gun
laws that's as of april 2021 we know
that the number has risen since you've
all day there's been some polling since
then that has shown that that number has
gone up
possibly approaching 60
that might seem low
um but remember this is there's an urban
rural divide going on here and it's it's
uh
people in the in rural areas will have
more guns and will favor having them a
lot more than the urban resident um
there is let's see 87 of americans that
includes 85 percent of gop voters want
legislation that prevents mentally ill
people from buying guns 85 87 and 85 of
the gop yeah
85 percent of geo so that's great it's
like that's a really powerful statistic
yes and 81 favor strict background
checks that's an overall 81. 64 percent
want to ban high-capacity magazines
that's over 10 rounds that's what you
were talking about right magazine that
was the word i was searching for yeah
and 63 percent want assault one an
outright assault weapons ban like we had
for what 20 years or so that just
expired not too long ago
the most alarming statistics i could
find though is this recent cbs news poll
i think it was it came out today maybe
the last couple of days
44 percent of republicans now say that
mass shootings are something we have to
accept
it's so strange to hear that
in contrast to this polling that 85 of
gop voters
want to prevent mentally ill people from
buying guns right like how did those two
things square with each other i think it
just square there's a percentage of that
that want it to change but don't think
it will so therefore they are kind of
more like it's not going to change
therefore we need to accept it as it is
and there is some reporting like if you
look at the
more conservative uh judicial branch
it's gotten more conservative it's
gotten it's hewn more towards
constitutional conservativism which
means second amendment kind of taking it
literally to to a point where it really
never was intended remember when the
second amendment was written people were
shooting guns with muskets and it was
like one little ball
and it took like a couple of minutes to
load that thing and now you know now now
it's a different story which is why it's
problematic to be
a strict constructionist or to try to
intuit
the
you know the hearts and minds and the
manner in which the founders
you know meant these words to be
put into use yeah why don't you get into
the second moment i know you had some
stuff on the second amendment yeah well
i mean i think you know so as we kind of
go through all of the
you know opposition points it's like
well we have a second amendment right
to
bear arms you know the second amendment
specifically
to quote it
says a well-regulated militia being
necessary to the security of a free
state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed and when you
kind of parse that and try to understand
what it's saying
you can't help but think well what is
well-regulated mean what does militia
mean and all of these
words and phrases over the years have
been interpreted by the judiciary
to the point where we've broadened how
we define those things
to the extent that we allow people to
bear arms in the way that they do today
uh there was a case
a supreme court case uh i think it was
13 years ago i'm not sure district of
columbia versus heller
where the court for the first time
recognized people's constitutional right
to own firearms as individuals not just
as members of a well-regulated militia
because prior to that you could say well
are you
are you a well-regulated militia when
you walk into an elementary school and
gun everyone down well heller
allows individuals to fall within that
definition which just doesn't make sense
right but when you think about what the
second amendment really means and how it
was intended
basically james madison
was thinking of it as a way for states
to repel the danger of the federal
government right right um at the time
state militias were basically people
that lived at home and they got they got
the call and they came out with their
guns the union being formed out of this
tension between states rights and
federal rights right at a time where
states really wanted to be kind of
independent nation states within
the republic we think about our country
as a democracy but it's really a
democratic republic what are the state's
rights vis-a-vis the federal government
and what should happen if the federal
government extends the boundaries in the
exercise of its power we need to reserve
the right for people to rise up against
that power which makes sense but nobody
like to your point of muskets nobody
could have imagined guns progressing to
the point that they are today and i
don't think any founding father
if they had been you know given a
looking glass to see what's occurring
today
would interpret what they meant by the
second amendment to allow what is
unfolding before our very eyes in real
time day in and day out
yeah
and
and so that one that one case basically
is what expanded
this uh
the aperture from
a well-regulated re well-regulated
regulated uh militia to individuals
right so
it allowed people to bear arms in their
homes right but it was not unlimited in
scope it did not permit
the right to keep and carry any weapon
in any manner whatsoever and for
whatever purpose
so there were sort of cons you know
restrictions on that
and and what i mean by that is it it is
totally constitutional to impose
conditions and qualifications on the
sale of arms like universal background
checks
nine out of ten support this we went
through the polls
what's interesting is is that half of
the people who are polled already
believe
that universal background checks are a
thing meaning federally mandated
background checks they don't realize
that actually many states don't don't
require this
um and one out of four guns are sold
without a background check
so
and background checks are criminal
background checks they're not like the
kid in uvalde hadn't hadn't didn't have
a criminal record so he would have
gotten cleared anyway um the there's an
argument out there that's saying
some people are saying let's you know
you have to be 25 to rent a car without
with without special dispensation maybe
we should do something 21 to you know
you have to be 21 to buy a six pack of
beer maybe you should have to be 21 to
um purchase a gun but there's a
columnist in the new york times uh ross
to do todd i don't forget how to i don't
know i know yeah
he uh
he
he is saying look instead of doing that
why don't you make it really hard for
troubled young men to get these guns and
one way of doing that isn't an outright
ban or an age limit
but if you are a young man and you want
this gun well then you have to go
through a lot more hoops than a 50 year
old sure you know uh so and the hoops
would include a reasonable
like a social media audio audit two
letters from people who can vouch for
you in writing that you're not you know
a strict background check some
counseling perhaps
something real something like how about
if you just required a a class
to be able to be licensed and then to
buy a weapon if you just had to take a
class like driver's head driver's ed
yeah and you had an instructor in front
of you
you would weed out a lot of these people
if you just had to take a class like
just that but there's nothing we can do
adam right
we can't do anything about this problem
we can all come together there's a
there's a uh
i can't wait to talk to senator booker
about this because i know there's a
group of senators a bipartisan group
trying to hash out something to get
something moving we'll see if that
prevails or not in the next weeks but um
it's so
it's so frustrating and infuriating that
it that we can't get off the dime on
this i was listening to uh scott
galloway the other day
it's sort of like okay we understand
where the right sits on this
we understand the left's perspective on
this as well
why can't we move the needle at all and
he called it a war between the wrong and
the ineffectual
right yeah not being able to basically
accomplish anything
and the other side being wrong-headed in
how they're thinking about this problem
and their their reluctance or failure to
address it at all
you know i was looking i was thinking
about it like why are guns so uniquely
american and you think
from a storytelling perspective where i
always default to we're a country born
of revolution and bondage where guns
played the key role of liberator and
oppressor we had the wild west
expansion the manhood that came along
with the guns the high plains drifter
the john wayne [ __ ] that happened in
real life in 19th century and then
obviously on the big screens then he had
in the 80s kind of this hip-hop culture
where guns became a way of life in the
inner cities and kind of manhood as well
as dominance
but other countries love westerns and
hip-hop and they don't have our problems
so then you come back around to this
bigger problem and it's not just access
to firearms but
why
like what is it about us
that we like why do we lack empathy and
responsibility for one another in a way
that other countries don't and i really
do believe that we do have that problem
like we we
don't care about another's welfare as
much as our own here and that's
different than the way it is in a lot of
countries i'm not saying that other
countries are you know perfect and
angelic or anything
but there is a
um
an acknowledgement that our fates are
tied up with one another yeah it's a
it's a great insight and i think it's
very true and i think it tracks back
to the genesis of the country where
liberty became the priority like all
these people who came to america so that
they could do what the [ __ ] they wanted
to right and that's bred into the dna of
how this country was born right and i
think over time
that empathy has constricted and extends
perhaps only to one's very small circle
and as we become more and more isolated
and less
sort of communitarian and how we live
our lives ensconced in our you know
homes on cul-de-sacs etc we're more and
more separated from our fellow
individuals i think that sphere of
empathy you know continues
to dwindle and what get what gets
eclipsed in all of this
is the other side of liberty which is
responsibility like you can't have
liberty without responsibility and in
the united states people are gung-ho for
liberty but when it comes to talking
about responsibility no one really wants
to rise to that occasion and this is
something i talked at length
with um about with uh with ryan holliday
when he was on the podcast recently
we didn't talk about it in the context
of of guns specifically but it's
certainly applicable to that like
we want what we want and we want to be
able to do whatever we want to do and
when it comes to our responsibility to
the collective we don't want to hear
about that and that is a very weird
um
american thing
it's it's a self-destructive seed
that seems to be like
replicating you know like it's it's
within that
if that's how we feel
there's a self-destructive kind of code
that's gonna just
could could destroy it all
because if you don't care and that's the
biggest problem why we can't and we're
getting more and more polarized and we
demonize one another to the point i i
realize i called anyone who went to an
nra convention an [ __ ]
which is demonizing but at the same time
you're yeah like you're calling yourself
out
i'm not i'm not saying i'm not saying
i'm not part of the problem what i am
saying is
both things can be true
and um
and we do have this empathy gap
and until we start to
respect one another and care about each
other's fates the problem is it does
feel like when you're on the left it
does feel like
we care about people's fates more than
the people who are the strict
individualists which are tend to be on
the right and so that's kind of comes
with its own thorny
um
inability to then uh
talk to each other because no one likes
being talked down to and no one likes
someone who's a selfish person so all
those we have to figure out a way
to look past that
um hopefully that's going to that's what
senators and congressmen are supposed to
be able to do right that's what politics
is about which is why
you know i i'm so interested to talk to
senator booker like why is this such an
intractable problem like what is the
lived experience of being in the senate
being passionate about this issue
and and not being able to kind of get
any traction to get
to get you know things voted on at the
very least like
how are those obstacles created faced
met and hopefully
you know at some point overcome well and
how do you live with yourself if you're
on the other side of it and your your
whole goal is to is to
scuttle votes like this like how do you
like do people live in an absence of
guilt and like i i i live with guilt as
a constant shut around
like the mentality of somebody who who
is trying to prevent all of these
measures from going into effect i mean
it is occam's razor like you can say
whatever you want and throw all those
oppositional arguments out there we need
to arm the schools with militia you know
the ad hominem attacks you're just a
libtard second amendment you know
whatever but
ultimately like what is the most obvious
thing that we could do right now we can
restrict access to deadly weapons
from people who who are not
suitable or mature enough to handle them
right can we not at least accomplish
that we all agree on this right it seems
like we're trying to block this from
getting past or being
put into
into motion i i have a really hard time
trying to understand and you know what
maybe i'm missing something
i'm not a guy who's like
the other argument being like they're
they're going to take all your guns away
like nobody's saying that no we're just
saying that they're getting that because
it did happen in australia right so
that's what happened in australia but
they had they passed a
huge kind of all-encompassing
uh
gun control measure and people did give
up there they don't have a second
amendment they don't have a second
amendment um
i also think it's funny these people
running for office
how often they're disparaging government
like you know marjorie taylor greene
does it all the time right she by the
way she works for the government she is
part of the government uh hates the
government she's part of she hates her
that's self-hating she hates herself dr
oz uh
has that funny video about like where
he's like firing weapons i mean it's
this video is bananas yeah wasn't he
like didn't he get famous because of
oprah
well i don't know what the beginning of
him being famous was but anyway overly
intrusive government that i wanted
bizarre that i want to be video like
because i think of him as the guy with
the daily talk show talking about like
health and alternative medicine and
stuff like that and like suddenly
he's like out shooting guns and you know
talking about all this stuff that like
is this real like that doesn't look like
pennsylvania this character because
you're running for office
yeah railing against the government to
your point uh you know in an attempt to
become part of the government yes they
rail against the government to try to
become part of the government so they
can do nothing when children are
murdered in their classroom it's a
strange obsession it really is yeah
it's also interesting there's a weird
weird like ironic twist to all of this
because those that
that that railed the hardest against
mass mandates in schools like kind of
decrying the mental health implications
of kids having to wear mass in the
classroom
are the same people who
are not interested in gun control
measures that would reduce the
likelihood of a school shooting
yes
it's uh and and want and want it to be
more militarized want to want the
classroom to be more militarized
what are the mental health implications
on kids of schools being hyper
well that that same times column uh is
basically saying he thinks like the more
militarized you make it the more you
bring up school shootings the more you
um have these kind of uh active shooter
drills the more likely some kid some
disturbed kid is gonna yeah so it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy
and uh
you know that kind of stuff happens like
we've talked about that hip-hop i think
last time we talked when we talked about
uh abortion we talked about those same
hypocrisies like
i want liberty but you can't have an
abortion um you know like and vice versa
i'm pro-choice but you have to wear the
mask and we've we talked about that it's
not necessarily an equal
thing but you know there is there is
that irony that we're always trying to
uh that often
it's the side of convenience um it's
just it's more grotesque in this
instance yeah yeah
uh before we move on i did want to
circle back on david frum yeah because i
think he has done some some compelling
writing on this again he's a he's a
conservative a traditional conservative
with a pretty rational take when you say
traditional conservative you mean like
just you know he was a he was a
republican i can't remember what
administration he worked in but you know
he has a long history of you know being
a conservative thinker
um but also a really smart guy
uh who has a really rational take on
who's who's real who is outraged by what
he's seeing right now in terms of
um
gun violence and has written a bunch of
pieces for the atlantic which i'll i'll
hyperlink in the show notes because i
think they're worth your time
and uh what else
anything else we want to point out on
this um we pivot to corey yeah the the
well i mean the the
when you when you think
about uh what david frum is saying is
basically some of the same stuff that
we've been talking about right like he
wants
rational
measures that make it harder for
for kids and innocent people to be
killed
and moss like
these are this is this is all we're
asking for so
i we we can only hope that that we're
heading in that direction
we need a little bit more than hope
yeah and it goes back to that despairing
when you see columbine and sandy hook
and nothing happens and here we are
again it did feel
different with uvalde it did because the
nation and and really the world was so
outraged and activated by that that
there was a sense like okay
maybe this is the point where the tide
turns
our greatest fear of course being that
we just move on and the way that our
news cycle
happens so quickly these days you know
that's my that's my fear
that we're just going to move on and
forget about it
until it happens again and then we'll
have the same conversation and the same
conversation so
that's what we hope doesn't happen
because we thought sandy hook was going
to be the end of the line right where
something would finally happen
and it didn't didn't work out right and
we should we should also point out that
in terms of of scotus
we're anticipating a decision it could
be in the next few weeks i think it's
meant for the fall but the the supreme
court
is on the precipice of of delivering an
opinion in the case of new york state
rifle and pistol association versus
bruin which is
a decision that could strike down
concealed carry bans even in the few
states that still have them so basically
that would mean
more guns more places
fewer checks
fewer protections
it's basically you know this punctuation
mark on how we're
moving backwards and and downwards and
to use david frum's words you know kind
of plunging toward or plunging towards
barbarism right and so because scotus is
is
you know obviously
unshackled from
public opinion and the legislature and
it's packed to the right right now so
they're positioned to make a decision
that could very well make that possible
there's a couple of uh of
things that are also popping up though
that can be looked at as positive i
believe that the
um policing the national kind of police
union consortium
that represents all the police unions in
different localities has come out um in
favor of of
uh
you know some gun control in the in the
wake of aldi
um that's happened
governor newsom they just passed a law
here in california that um you can sue
the uh
somebody who's involved in a mass
shooting you can sue them and you can
sue anybody involved in uh and helping
them carry out
their mass shootings it's basically
using that same abortion law that's been
passed in some states in republican
states and using that same lawsuit idea
that you can think you can
as a private citizen can sue someone who
gets an abortion can see the doctor same
idea in in this sense you can sue the
gun uh shop that sells the weapon um you
can sue the person who's involved in the
family that's involved um so there's
there's there are people trying
different
new tactics new things this police union
is not typically someone that an
organization that gets in on to onto
progressive causes
so the fact is this should not be a
progressive should not be a right or
left cause
it's uh the welfare of our children
yeah and as the polling
uh demonstrates it isn't a left or right
thing it's it's an everybody thing it is
all right so we're gonna take a quick
break and we'll reconvene with the the
good senator and hopefully he has some
some thoughts for us
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but i want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people i know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised i'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner our affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition excellence by
providing access to thousands of highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richroll.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering 10 off an
annual membership when you use the promo
code rr health at checkout this is
life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
meals.richroll.com promo code rrhealth
for ten dollars off an annual membership
all right
let's get back to the show hey rich how
are you how's it going man it's it's
been a emotionally raw stretch but uh
yeah you know i wouldn't want people
think wrongly of me when i say i go to
bed with you uh often
i promise not to say that publicly
although this is being recorded now so
that could be held against me
but i just finished uh just finished
your talk with a guy i've loved uh
uh even though he back then he was a
think tank on the other side of the
aisle but i've always loved uh
uh arthur brooks he's just such a brooks
yeah that was a great conversation yeah
thank you i mean i'm so i'm touched and
honored that uh you make the time to
listen to the show i can't believe
that's possible but you know arthur
makes my job easy he's such a you know a
beautiful
font of wisdom and it is interesting as
you know him being somebody who was head
of a conservative think tank um my sense
is that he he really doesn't want to
talk about politics that's not his
interest level right now i mean you
covered it well which you know all of us
being in our 50s
he definitely
has made a shift away from this crazy
think tank world but he was moving that
way he wrote this amazing book about
love um which i think was one before
this one
that i i've
my stack of books right now is just
trying to figure out how do we talk to
each other in a country that's spiraling
uh in in kind of a into a culture of
contempt um
and he's thought been really thoughtful
about that i think highly influenced by
the dalai lama
yeah i think that's i think that's
accurate and uh you know i think that's
a good place to just jump right into it
i mean i know your time is tight and i
really appreciate you i love you
they said 15 minutes
i i've been looking to talk to rich roll
for like since i started listening to
his podcast i fell in love with your
podcast it was one of your best of years
you know like at the end of the year you
do the
you sample from all the ones and
so i i've been looking to to have a
conversation with you for a very long
time so i told myself to give me at
least an extra 15 minutes because i knew
i was going to fanboy all over you for
the first uh first 15 we wouldn't get to
the subject matter well you got me all
buttered up and i'm going to hold you to
that because i'm definitely you know
somebody who wants to get you in the
studio and we'll do the full kitten
caboodle podcast at at some point when
you're your journey your journey i read
founding finding ultra and
uh i think that you can see in my
opinion the universe sort of using you i
think that not only athletics but also
your struggles with with addiction have
made your power of empathy and your
ability to connect you know i always say
that broken people
uh we're all broken more than we maybe
want to admit but you you not only does
it let good stuff in but it also creates
more points of contact which you can
connect with other broken people and
i think that uh you have this uh
wonderful ability to
uh connect with the people you interview
that in a real way in a substantive way
to go a little deeper than some some of
the
general interviews we often see i think
it's a gift
i appreciate that it's uh it's
it's an honor to be able to do it and
it's certainly nourishing for me and uh
to be able to kind of give it back to
the audience is just you know something
that just gives my life purpose and
meaning
so i'm very grateful to be on this
journey and to be talking to you today
my friend
thank you let's get into it yeah please
go ahead
um
you know obviously uh
obviously um
you know the country is under a lot of
strain right now we're we're uh you know
enduring um some challenges not the
least of which is
all of the mass shootings uh what
transpired in uvalde and subsequent
incidents that we've all uh born witness
to these tragic events
and so i really wanted to kind of focus
the limited time that that we have with
you today on the subject of gun violence
and and gun control and i thought it
might be beneficial
to just hear your perspective like what
is your bird's eye view on kind of where
we're at as a nation how are you
thinking about this issue right now
and and perhaps like some thoughts on
why this is so
intractable in terms of finding
solutions so i'm a kid that grew up in
the suburbs and uh new jersey and
not part of a hunting culture or my
granddad to take me out once but you
know it's a suburban town outside of of
new york and gun violence didn't affect
my life
but i've lived the last um
got since the late 90s in new york new
jersey in the central ward and
gun violence immediately impacted my
life on my first nights
sleeping
in an apartment i got across the street
from the projects i eventually moved
into them
i started hearing gunshots and at night
i still remember coming out one day and
there being a sort of tail end of a
shooting
and since then i've lost uh young kids
i've known
uh to gun violence and and seen the
horrific everyday realities of
gun violence in america and it's often
the violence we don't talk about it's
stunning to me how
we as a nation
doesn't even pop into our consciousness
unless we have these horrific mass
shootings but every single day
uh
on average more than 300 americans are
shot over 100 americans die
and the violence is everything from
domestic violence which we don't talk
about
to suicides which we don't talk about
enough
um and now we have this stunning rise of
of hate in our country where since 9 11
we've lost more americans due to
americans killing americans right-wing
groups from synagogues to churches
to supermarkets
um and then and then obviously uh school
shootings like we just had so i it's a
very personal issue for me uh
i i i
you know i i'm some of my own personal
trauma
uh being in and around the shootings and
and so i came here
um as the only united states senator
that lives in a low-income black and
brown uh
neighborhood who's had shootings on
their block most recently in 2018 a
young man shahad who i i used to live in
the same building with
um the police
officer who was giving me the account
said it was like his head blew up it was
an assault rifle that he got
and so it's been frustrating to me that
um
to live in a country where
uh you know
since the time that you and i have been
alive as guys in their 50s we've had
more people die to gun violence than in
every single war in america combined
yeah and so when you start asking me why
something hasn't changed
um i i think it's too easy and
convenient to say
it's just washington
because we've seen
change happen against impossible odds
before when four little girls died in
the bombing in birmingham
you you saw a nation mobilize
to demand change and so i remind people
all the time
about this place
you know there's an old trope saying
here that they say often that change
doesn't come from washington it comes to
washington you know it wasn't a bunch of
guys on the senate floor in the
in the 1920s that said hey fellas
let's give these women a right to vote
it happened because people demanded it
uh as frederick douglass says
if there's no struggle there's no
progress power concedes nothing without
a demand
and so we have tolerated for a very long
time in this country a level of carnage
and violence and death that we've almost
normalized because days and days go by
without us
doing enough and so
i can give you stuff that you know and
i've heard listen to you
uh you enough of your podcast and i've
heard you express
understandable skepticism if not
cynicism about washington and politics
there are very powerful lobbies there's
money
there's um
uh
you know people's ambition
you know there is a real consequence to
congress people running in red districts
where
districts have been drawn
where they're always worried about being
primaried by somebody on their right i
was on meet the press recently with a
guy who just lost a senate race who
lowered violence in his north carolina
city 50 but he was running against
somebody that had a gun in their belt
he said for most of their commercials
and he lost in a primary because the guy
casted him soft on guns
but i i don't think that i think that's
a convenient and easy excuse just to
blame it on washington it's almost like
surrendering responsibility and not
understanding that we all have a role to
change this nightmare and it's more than
just those
real things that i just i just mentioned
yeah i think uh
you know that that makes me
you know want to know more about and my
colleague adam skolnick is is on the
line too and i know he wants to chime in
on this
the the kind of lived experience of you
being a legislator a senator and and and
what that experience is like that
perhaps we're not aware of like if there
is to the extent that there's
frustration like why can't we just get a
law passed or what is actually going on
like when you
uh as somebody who cares deeply about
this issue and and is working so
diligently to
change the law and and and move our
country forward in a new direction on
this
on this subject matter like what are the
obstacles that you encounter on a daily
basis or or what do we as the public
you know not see about
what that is like for you so
look i've seen the best of this place
and i've seen the worst of it you know
where we've been able to hammer out
really great bills you know our criminal
justice system is an outrage we're a
nation that takes our addicted are
mentally ill
or poor or black and brown we stiff
stick them in jails when they often need
help
or health care or counseling or trauma
or treatment
and we put them in our jails and you
know we've passed some good bills to try
to start changing
this nation from being
a the country where we still are with
one out of every three incarcerated
women on the planet earth are in the
united states
and so we've passed some bills that have
liberated thousands of people that
that's the best of us
we have a long way to go though and i've
seen the worst of us you know we just
passed an anti-lynching bill
um more than a century after it was
first introduced
when thousands of blacks were being
killed and we couldn't even make
lynching a federal crime until 2022.
and so i
i
i
i
you know i've seen the um the corporate
gun lobby and how powerful they are
i've seen them change
i think after columbine
wayne lapierre said you know we need to
make universal background checks he was
for a lot of things
but the culture has slipped on on the
sort of
uh
within the nra world where they are
resisting and fighting any change
whatsoever and they are a very powerful
lobby
for people who are concerned about um
real re-election
um
[Music]
and so like right now we're we're
we're
i've watched now i've been here eight
nine years
and i have seen those americans who are
really willing to
do something different dig in organize
uh put show more pressure on politics
um change laws on states you know since
parkland there's been a whole lot of
state laws that have changed for the
better
um
but here um it's been more difficult i
think we're actually going to get
something done you know i was talking
with uh
senator murphy and a group of house
members
that there's there's hope here that
something can get done but i'm i'm going
to be candid it's going to be very
incremental
necessary things but nowhere near
sufficient to end the kind of carnage
what we're seeing on a regular basis
yeah
um senator booker is you're talking
about the election cycle and and the
pressure
to get reelected um how you know when we
see these stats of the nra and how much
they're contributing to people like
mitt romney or
you know mitch mcconnell people who you
could argue are bigger than the nra in
some ways they have their own kind of
brand but they're still under the sway
of an organization like that does that
speak to how hard it is to raise money
and compete in politics like what is the
draw there or like is it more that
they're afraid of the primary like what
what do you think is the draw for some
of these bigger names that could you
think you would be able to win without
them so again you're getting into the
psychology of of your colleagues is
often a uh
a dangerous odyssey you can lose your
own mind trying to figure out people's
different motivations
um
the nra is not the biggest donor down
here and and and money i mean it's
really one of the toxins of our of our
of of our government i think uh when
citizens united passed and corporations
now can port tons and tons of money
strengthens the corporate gun lobby
because remember these are
corporations who are having a field day
they're selling guns in our country
you know at a level that we could have
never imagined every man woman and child
in america from babies to 99 year olds
could have one gun and then we'd still
have 70 million more guns out in our
streets
um but i don't know if it's just the
money they're contributing and and
you know again i like for example i gave
up all corporate money it was fourth
center to do so i just didn't want to
give anybody
reason to question my motives
um but i know that there as you said
there are people that can raise money if
they didn't get the whatever thirty
thousand dollars from the corporate gun
lobby but they they i think their power
a lot of it lies in their ability to
mobilize people and get them out to vote
singularly on this issue
and that's a pretty powerful if you know
you're in a
election where
if it if you don't have that a rating
and you're going to be you're going to
be beat up by it by somebody else who's
who really has whipped up this idea
that um that that this person is going
to be a part of the
um group in washington is going to try
to take away your guns
you know when gun sales spike when
democrats get elected because they have
again and you can listen to the to the
rhetoric because they're told people are
told that you're going to lose your
people who believe a very narrow version
believe that they're going to lose your
gun right so that's a that's a base not
in my world but that's a base i think
for
uh that people are concerned about in
primaries
yeah what's interesting is that
that being said
it does seem like the nra is out of step
with its constituency because the
polling demonstrates
clearly that most people are in favor of
rational gun control and yet the nra
still wields so much power
to you know rebut
the public sentiment on this issue and
so i guess i'm curious about
you mentioned
senator murphy chris murphy from
connecticut he's put together this
bipartisan
consortium of legislators to really work
on rational gun control like are you
like sanguine about the possibilities
here because that does seem like a
something that's new and different from
what we've seen in the past yeah i just
want to dwell on that point you made
first which is such an important point
and i should have mentioned it already
this is not a partisan issue
it really is not and the problem often
with our country is we we try to um
reduce things into the binary world as
stem or republican
when i've listened to your show enough
to know that you realize that's not the
case i mean the the stranglehold that
big ag has down here is not a partisan
issue
chemicals are being sprayed on our our
foods that are in our bloodstream breast
milk and like it's not a partisan issue
tech issues are not partisan issues and
and we as americans have so much more in
common the lines
uh that divide us are nowhere near as
strong as the ties that bind us but but
this this uh
political industrial complex
uh that will try to parse us along these
tribes uh i think that's and make us
believe that we're different that's a
problem there's a whole raft of common
sense gun safety things that i've seen
comedians go to nra conventions and ask
people about universal background checks
and you just see these nra members
saying all this about i'm worried about
my guns being taken oh but
but you know
universal background checks heck yeah we
need to have them to stop criminals from
getting guns so this is not a partisan
issue amongst americans it's a partisan
issue down here
and um and that's a lot of the
disconnect um folks have got to
um
on the republican side democratic side
whatever you identify begin to make this
a a central issue in in your political
behavior as far as me being uh
optimistic i'm look i'm a prisoner of
hope but i always
differentiate hope from optimism hope
stares the wretched truth
of the world in the face doesn't deny it
but but still believes ultimately that
something can be done and so i've seen
this come around and i can't if i lost
hope that we could do something i don't
think i could continue doing this job i
will tell you again
that washington watchers
do think that there are the makings
right now because of you know chris
murphy said this to me today so this to
a group of us today
that his sense was that
a lot of folks went home
and and heard from people within their
that identify as their tribe the
republicans
and and were so dismayed about this
because at the end of the day
we are all hugging our children if you
have them before they go to school
there's a lot of that worry i think that
they're feeling which is opening the
door to do a little bit but i do not
have
a belief
um that in this bill we're going to see
the kind of comprehensive things
that most americans republican democrat
independent would want to see but we got
to start just like trevor noah's uh
monologue the other day like we have to
start somewhere and we got to iterate uh
on that and just uh just to get any and
i'm sorry i love i love history
people look at the civil rights movement
thinks it was in the 60s people started
in the in
you know
uh uh you know a philip randolph and
others were working on a march on
washington far before the one we know
about uh in the 60s they were doing
activism and protests and working and
making small changes uh thurgood
marshall was out there changing laws and
and more so i agree with you the the
this first of all we have started the
parkland kids the moms demand action
gabby giffords organization there
there's a chapter in every single state
um of mom's demand action for example
that are making a difference in local
elections city county state elections so
this is a movement the question is is
are you a part of it or not because i
think what martin luther king said at
very frustrating points
in the in the civil rights movement
remember his letters from the birmingham
jail were not to the
racists he was talking to good people
and what he said is what we have to
repent in this day and age and these
words echo in this moment what we have
to repent for is not simply the
vitriolic words and violent actions of
the bad people but the appalling silence
and inaction of the good people and so
that's the question is to me it's very
binary i don't i don't don't tell me
what your beliefs are
show me who you are through your actions
are you part of the movement to change
these laws are you doing more than you
did before uvaldi are you doing more
than you did before buffalo or you're
doing the same things you were doing
before those two mass shootings and
expecting other people to make the
change that you want to see in your
country yeah you spoke about um this
kind of increased contempt um
in terms of the volume i guess you
that's speaking to polarization but also
speaking to kind of
i guess information silos and how that
can turn up the the volume and the heat
on some uh issues like this one um it
seems like a tragedy like this
the break the breaking of all of us like
if the united states is our common body
and we're we're broken it seems like
that should be the place to latch on and
to do some good right i mean that's what
we were talking about but maybe before
uh we started to record this this
interview uh how how
a time of brokenness can be a time can
be the perfect time to come together
are you seeing anything like that uh i
know that you're kind of
trying to
to make us not expect too much from this
coming law but are you are you seeing
any of that are you hearing any of that
in the hallways
a little bit more coming together at all
so i do think that they're hurt
and and
shattered more than broken how much we a
lot of us have been
is creating a climate for change and and
the rhythms
of washington dc are often in those
moments where
of where we share a common pain
sometimes we can find common purpose and
that's again one of the reasons why i
think we're going to get something
incremental done or at least i'm hoping
and praying that we will
um
but i i have to be candid with you we
had a hearing today
all about uh replacement theory and for
those who don't know what that is
it's been it's been around for
generations it was around about the
catholics and the southern europeans
that were coming here to replace
protestant americans um it's this idea
that there is a quote unquote true
american i'm a black guy who can who
skip gates trace my history back to the
1640s but um in this country but
there's this idea uh that that uh
and you hear it you remember that
they're marching with tiki torches in
virginia jews will not replace us
so
the the the hearing the professors that
were there and the experts that were
there at this hearing it was stunning to
hear and to look at the data about the
mainstreaming of these views he he
really called it just like this
resurgence of the clan in the 1920s
which then it was a lot of catholics
hate and the like and how we're at a
perilous moment for our democracy
where you're seeing larger and larger
portions
view on us versus them within this
country and not just us where we're all
one people with one destiny and so i
would be i would be
i don't want to candy coat the truth of
our country right now
there is a rise in hate there is a rise
in resentment there is a culture of
contempt there are these devices that
are in our lives
now that have algorithms
that are profiting off of making us
uh more
emotional and more involved i tell the
story even about i'm pointing to my tv
where
you know a friend of mine had a show on
cnn his name is van jones called
crossfire
and i love what brene brown says she
says it's hard to hate up close so pull
people in
and
they decided when it hurt him and newt
gingrich realized they they were
approximate to each other and had lots
in common they wanted to do the last
segment as ceasefire
and then after a few episodes of that
the producers stopped them because they
said ratings were going down
so we have got people who are who are
realizing the incentive their corporate
incentive their political incentive as i
said in the hearing if i yelled at
donald trump during the state of the
union address if i heckled him and
screamed you lie you liar
i may have had a really great
fundraising quarter the next quarter
i know that because when somebody yelled
that to barack obama they had an
incredible great fundraising quarter
and so we're building this powder keg
right now
where we've literally seen people
whipped up to storm the capital of the
united states and remember they had
symbols of anti-semitism and racism
there where peoples
are being preyed upon their
vulnerabilities their hurt their trauma
their fears are being preyed upon
uh by leaders
and that that's my biggest worry for my
country right now for our country i i
really worry
that if we can't figure this out if our
tribalism becomes deeper and it's no
longer an objective analysis hey this
person believes in these values these um
ideas and this ideas but it's more
uh tribalism we demonize each other we
we we so uh hate each other that we
can't even talk to each other
um
i worry about the future of our country
we have got to figure out a way and is
this tied to the violence that we are
seeing absolutely it is
and and so i
just will finish this point by saying to
you that i'm not despondent because i
believe in the
radical redemptive power of love and
i've seen the data the scientific data
that love goes viral too in fact if
you're as a stanford researchers
uh to richard our alma mater uh that
have shown that just witnessing a kind
act changes your biochemistry and makes
you more likely to make change and you
can follow it two or three degrees of
separation but we are going to need a
lot more committed
americans to despite your
whipped up differences with somebody
that you can still find
ways to create
connection and see common dignity and
see common destiny and when you ask me
about how things get done down here how
they really get done
one of the best examples of getting
through the crap and the
obstacles
shows
is a story of my implicating myself and
my own bias we all have implicit biases
and there's a guy who's retiring named
inhofe an oklahoma
oklahoma um
uh senator who you know we vilify on our
side sometimes he carried a snowball
down to the senate floor to show that
there was no climate change but when i
got down here my mentor guy named bill
bradley told me
go to dinner with your colleagues find
ways to have one-on-ones with them and i
went to bible study in inhofe's office
and i'll never forget walking in and i
saw
on his uh shelf
a picture of him and this challenged my
implicit bias because i never thought
i'd see this kind of picture i saw a
picture of him in a little black girl
and i i said sir who who's that and he
says it's my daughter and he tells me
this powerful story about him adopting
her at a tough circumstances fast
forward
months later many months later there's a
big education bill going through and i
want to get an amendment on this bill
about homeless and foster kids and i'm
told there's no amendments being allowed
lamar alexander was blocking the bill
but i remember this point of human
connection and i went to uh inhofe
summoning the spirit of his daughter and
the connection i felt with his humanity
um that we often don't see when we're on
different sides of the political aisle
and i'll never forget he told me i will
co-sponsor your amendment on a bill that
no amendments were being allowed i had
this powerful chairman then i got chuck
grassley then we got other republicans
and it's now the law of the land and
that's just one small story but i think
we need millions of those stories in all
of our lives to begin to start to heal
the fabric and break through the bias
and the venom and the and all those who
profit off of our hate or our contempt
for each other very powerfully put uh
and and and beautifully stated i mean
thank you for that i mean certainly
love connection these are the antidotes
to the rift that is increasingly
dividing us
and the misalignment of incentives
whether technological or economic that
are driving this i mean we're
close enough in age senator that we
remember a time when
a crisis befell our country it brought
us together it didn't drive us apart
into our silos and make us argue with
each other and it really is an
existential crisis and if we can't see
our way forward from that
none of the other issues are ever going
to get addressed so i appreciate you
pointing that out and i know your time
is
running out with us
but um
it was amazing to have a few minutes to
talk to you and i appreciate you sharing
with us and our audience and and i
really do hope that
at some point in the not too distant
future i can sit down with you in person
and and do a full-blown podcast hey rich
can i make one more uh sure perhaps
emotional plea to your audience i i
love your pod podcast i love listening
to the two you
uh go edit uh uh during uh during the uh
the new kind of evolution of your
podcast where you have this you two
interstitially
and i just trust and believe that not
only is your podcast strong but it
appeals to people across
the political spectrum and and from all
different backgrounds and
the appeal i want to make to you is that
um
i i was i um i i was doing a new york
times
editorial and they asked me they were
doing fun questions at the end they were
asking interviewing all the democratic
presidential candidates and they would
ask me funny questions and they asked me
a question what was the biggest mistake
you've ever made and i thought they
think they thought they were going to
get a light answer and i said look the
biggest mistake i made
was when i was living in these high-rise
projects in the lobby of the building i
lived there for eight years this place
called brick towers
and i watched these little amazing boys
grow up all black boys
the the leader of the crew was my dad
incarnate and they were so similar uh
they were both whip smart charismatic
born leaders both born at or below the
poverty line both weren't raised by
their mothers raised by their
grandmothers there was just so many
serious similarities eerie to me one day
i came home smelling something i hadn't
smelled since the days of the enchanted
broccoli forest uh
rich
uh i spelled it often at stanford but i
smelled it in my lobby which was pot
and you know stanford students have a
lot more wider margins to experiment
with drugs than black kids in inner city
communities and i immediately thought to
myself i gotta lean in more and i took
them to the movies and i took them
uh you know out to diners i asked them
what their dreams were and they were
really humble dreams
um i still remember uh when one of them
told me they wanted to
learn how to repair cars and maybe one
day have a shop and i boom i thought
okay i'm going to fix you guys up with
mentors that can help you with all of
your dreams and made commitments to them
that i didn't immediately follow through
on because i was too busy i was running
for to become mayor of the city of
newark and even though i was busy and
didn't follow through they would still
greet me in the lobby on the end of long
campaigning days and cheer me on lift me
up and then i get elected
and i have death threats against me so
they surround me with police officers
stationed cops in
my in the lobby of the building and the
project safest projects i think i've
been in a long time but the kids i don't
care who you are high school kids don't
want to hang out where the police are so
i just didn't see these young people but
in the back of my mind i'm like i'm on a
mission to help all the children of the
city i'm not i know i'll reconnect with
them soon and then a month into my time
in office i'm called to uh court street
in newark and i get there after a
shooting and there's a body covered up
and i barely affirm
um i barely affirmed the the death on
the sidewalk and i'm too busy
ministering to the lead to the living
and telling them what we're going to do
to drive crime down
and um
i get home that night and i'm going
through my blackberry reading reports
and the
name of the murder
was hassan the young man from my lobby
and i will never
tell you
talk about shattered
god literally put
my dad in front of me my dad used to
talk about the conspiracy of love all
the small acts of kindness that helped
him get from a rural poor boy black boy
in the 1930s and 40s to become an ibm
executive all the acts of kindness
people going out of their way and here i
had a chance to pay it forward and i'll
never forget going to his funeral which
was like in the bottom the perry's
funeral home in newark
and it was like descending into the hull
of a ship we were all tied together
in grief wailing and moaning chained to
this horrific daily occurrence in
america which is another young boy in a
box
and and and it haunts me to this day and
i regret it to this day that i didn't do
more
and so i i don't know what it will take
for all of us
to understand that we are so connected
that what you do matters
no matter how busy you are there's
something more you can do to end this
death the pain the hurt the the
devastation that happens when a young
man commits suicide
or or or a woman gets killed by her
boyfriend
or a a a gun
a legal weapon because it was not a
background check gets into the streets
of communities like mine and is used for
a horrific murder and so my appeal to
the folks here is that democracy is not
a spectator sport it really isn't you
get the government you deserve
and people before us
sacrifice sweat blood we're willing to
die
to try to bend the arc of of this
nation's moral
truth and and if there's not if there's
ever a time
uh to to lean in more to change
something that's not partisan it's it's
right now because you and i i i worry
even though i think we're going to pass
some legislation i worry that that you
may call me up and say hey can we have
another 15 minutes to have a
conversation about why do we have
another mass shooting and this time god
forbid as if you're a listener here
god forbid it's your neighborhood your
school your mosque your supermarket your
neighborhood and you're wondering why i
didn't do more to stop that pain and
that horror from visiting upon your life
wow
that's
amazing uh amazing words senator thank
you so much for telling us that and
sharing that it's it's like it must
weigh heavy
every day these kinds of
things that you've witnessed and then
also hear about you must get every day
and another tragic story like that kind
of
how do you
how do you deal with that on a daily
basis like the the the responsibility
you carry and and the the weight of all
of that look i i am who i am because uh
a community that i'm not from
uh
embraced me a young law student from
yale who thought i was uh some kind of
savior
and uh knocked me on my ass uh people
like
frank hutchins and uh miss virginia
jones miss yancy you know
um
miss miss miss wright i can tell you the
women
who taught me i say i got my ba from
stanford by my phd on the streets of
newark and
i have too many stories about gun
violence but
i i uh
you know
on the worst moment for me
because it was just so traumatizing
we hear these stories about the
shootings where we're not seeing the
bodies while i was on a scene of a
shooting where teenager got shot
multiple times and i was the
[Music]
person trying to stop them from bleeding
to death
and it was the most gruesome thing i had
i had ever experienced his foamy blood
was coming from his mouth blood pouring
from his chest and i just i i just was
doing i think about it now i no training
so i'm sticking my hand in his mouth
thinking if i just can clear away the
passage for him to breathe because he's
choking on his blood and
i remember that night trying to scrub
this boy's blood off my hands and i
remember i have never felt more anger at
my country than i did then and i never
felt more of a more of a
of wanting to quit and just be done with
this why was i even trying when the
problems seemed so much bigger than me
and
i came down into that lobby where the
boys hang out the next morning and
walk through the lobby it was early in
the morning so nobody was there and i
walk into the courtyard
and you know this is why i believe in a
larger power because i was drowning i
was done it was over and then i see the
tenant president this elderly woman this
virginia jones
who
had her son murdered in the lobby in
which i i lived uh
years before i moved in a woman had
every reason to move out of those
projects in fact i know the money she
made i know where she works she didn't
have to live in this dangerous
neighborhood especially after her son
was killed and i remember walking out
and being frozen because i saw her back
to me
and then she turns around almost like
she could hear my hurt
and then she sees me
and she
does the only thing that i needed at
that moment not to say a word she just
opened her arms and i ran across that
courtyard like a little boy running to
his mom and i'm much bigger than she is
but i felt like i disappeared in her
arms and she held me
and this is the gift she gave me as i
started sobbing
she just said two words over and over
that were
hold on to now when i hurt and when i
get angry and when i don't understand my
country
and where i want to give up
and i think about women like that who
never give up i think about
kids from parkland who turn their pain
into purpose i think of moms to man
action people have lost and turned their
hurt
uh into action and this woman just rubs
my back and she says two words that i
held on to during my times mayor and in
my toughest days here and she just says
to me she's rubbing my back she says
stay faithful stay faithful stay
faithful
and so
i believe that what real hope is about
it's like miss jones it's like hope is
the act of conviction that despair will
never have the last word that no matter
how much it visits upon you
you still have agency you still have
power even if it's just the defiance of
keeping going and not giving up and so
yeah
i see shrines on my streets teddy bears
and candles too many damn times and it's
unfortunately black children or latino
children who don't seem to count as much
sometimes to the media
uh uh they don't seem to get the same
coverage and i get angry about systems
uh that date back to
you know when we had overt redlining
they've created a lot of the pain and
hurt but i will tell you this we've come
this far by faith and i have no right to
give up especially when others didn't
and the real challenge i see again
is how do we make other people care
i don't i don't need to change one
person's mind who might believe
that we shouldn't pass universal
background checks or gun licensing or i
don't have to change one person's mind
all we have to do is get the people who
share our beliefs which is the majority
of us to do a lot more to show their
faith because as my religious tradition
says
and it's a terrible foreboding thing to
say but it says faith without works is
dead
very true um
wow i'm just trying to process
everything that you just shared it's
such a powerful story and i think if you
can carry that resonance of of hope and
channel that into action
um it's inspiring for the rest of us who
might feel paralyzed or powerless or as
if you know our actions don't really
matter because they do and in this
democratic republic that we're
privileged to live in it's incumbent
upon all of us to shoulder that
responsibility and and do what we can
uh to put in motion uh the better world
that we want for ourselves and and
future generations and a lot of you know
you have a lot of athletes that listen
to this
and it's very obvious like nothing
worthwhile is easy nothing that i
watched you do
you don't just get up in the morning and
win a national championship or win a
heavyweight boxing match it is hard it
takes endurance and resilience and
pushing through pain and pushing through
a setback but that's what it takes to be
great and i do believe in the greatness
of this country i think
american history is a perpetual
testimony to the achievement of the
impossible but we who are the inheritors
of this impossible dream that is america
have got to as i fail to do in that one
instance with my dad we've got to prove
worthy of it by paying it forward
through our sacrifice and our struggle
you you mentioned um
just if i could trouble you with just
one last recommendation because you've
been so generous with your time but
it's uh
you you mentioned that you're you're
you're asking us to give more and do
more
and i see like a lot of the the volume
on the political discussion has gone up
the frequency that the average person is
talking about politics has gone way up
and a lot of that you pointedly pointed
out is related to our phones and
obviously that addiction
but
often what we're doing is just shouting
into the void there's not really much
getting accomplished other than a bunch
of information soup which doesn't help
us actually it hurts us what what would
you say would be some you've mentioned
some great organizations what kind of
if there's a couple concrete steps that
you could recommend for listeners to
kind of get involved or a first step to
getting more active
yeah i would find others and connect
with others that are that are doing that
i mean this is the great thing about
america now and these devices i have to
say because i don't want to say there's
only negative to them is that your
fingertips away are connect the ability
to connect with people that are probably
two or three steps ahead of you
sometimes 10 or a mile ahead of you and
understanding what makes a difference
makes a change and so do some research
find these organizations find these
people who are committed to this kind of
change um and and and never
underestimate that you can do you can
make a difference i've seen i've seen
uh uh
incredibly imaginative young people find
ways to bring pressure to bear amongst
people in power it's really
extraordinary and and and this will be
it because my staff always stands up and
when i
you gotta you gotta go but i am a
i am i am the living evidence that
you doing a little bit of something can
change the world and i always say this
because there was this white guy sitting
on a couch in jersey in 1965
uh watching tv it's just chilling out i
think it was a sunday
and uh
and this is back when we only had three
channels and they break away the movie
most americans were watching that night
was a movie called judgment at nuremberg
and and suddenly he sees
this these these black these not these
these people on a bridge called the
edmund pettus bridge being viciously
beaten
and he's so disturbed by it he's like i
gotta go to alabama and then he laughs
at himself because he just started a
business he can't afford a ticket even
to alabama so this guy does what is a
great american tradition he just thinks
to himself okay i'm just gonna do the
best i can with what i have where i am
and he does a calculus in his mind and
he thinks to himself okay i could spare
one hour a week of pro bono work and he
does what i just advised you to do calls
around back then he didn't have an
internet calls around to figure out who
might need a one hour pro bono civil
rights legal work and he finds this
young woman she's now 93 years old but
this young and she's still ahead of the
same organization finds this one who's
head of the fair housing council in
northern new jersey and she's like
hallelujah jesus i need help because we
don't know how to stop
they won't let black people live in
these neighborhoods they keep showing up
and they get steered away and he goes
well let's figure something out and they
designed this sting operation where they
get volunteer white couples to volunteer
to follow black couples around
and so what happens is
he goes four years later i get this case
file of this
uh black family moving up from the south
trying to getting turned away from house
after house he goes we set up the sting
they fall in love with this house
they're told it's already sold they
leave the white couple comes the house
is for sale they put a bid on the house
on papers are drawn up on the day of the
closing the white couple doesn't show up
the lawyer does and and the black guy
and they confront the real estate agent
real estate agent doesn't give up he
gets up and punches the lawyer in the
face saves the doberman pincher on the
black guy all this kind of rigmarole and
next thing you know that black family
moves into this affluent uh all-white
town as the father would say that we are
the four raisins in the tub of sweet
vanilla ice cream that family is my
family
that's my store
that's how i got to where i grew up and
by 18 years old i was a two position
high school all-american uh on my way to
stanford university on a full
scholarship and i would not be in this
senate office right now
uh if it wasn't for some white guy years
before i was born deciding to give one
hour a week of pro bono work so don't
tell me
that that your actions right now if
you're listening to this
can't make a difference what you do if
it's righteous and for a cause of
justice and peace and security or the
highest of human virtues
love
it resonates it reverberates it it goes
out across space and time and makes a
difference you may not live to see it or
even have the gift of knowing it but but
it makes a difference and now more than
ever we need that kind of radical
love and consistency to say i'm going to
give a little bit
every day or every week or whatever you
can do
for the cause of my country fantastic
wow i'm inspired adam what are we gonna
do we gotta do more than we're doing i
gotta i gotta do at least one hour a
week i mean this is this is crazy
that's an unbelievable story thank you
so much you guys thank you so much yeah
thank you thank you senator booker
really appreciate it uh have a great
evening and and and look forward to
crossing paths against i hope to see you
in l.a yeah yeah for sure i'm holding
you to it
i'm trust me man we've got a lot of
talks we need to talk about america's
broken food system and how washington dc
has created a system where 98
where only two percent of our ag
subsidies go to the thing we tell people
to eat the most of so i'm looking
forward to that 100 percent and my staff
is all here
they're all waving
hey everybody
thanks for letting the senator run long
i thought he was getting 15 minutes we
got 45 40 almost 50 minutes so you've
been very generous thank you everybody
thank you all right
thank you guys
[Music]
you